hb tendre et tête de bois rafraîchira la
mémoire à certains d'entre vous michèle
torr franck alamo richard anthony et les
autres sont actuellement en tournée des
artistes dans les tubes ont déjà près
d'un demi siècle
la nostalgie toute une époque le public
en redemande paraît-il richard tripot
jean-bernard hier tout est sale ils
n'ont certes plus lâche dendre mais
certainement encore la tête de bois et à
chaque représentation
ils font le plein ils se sont tous en
coulisses les gens jaloux trenca la
moule en cire le web et autres richard
anthony une bande de copains qui
revivent et font revivre les années 60
en tout une douzaine d'artistes réunis
pour plus de trois heures de spectacle
et un enchaînement ininterrompu de culte
et de souvenirs
à
ma vie quand une fleuriste ion et au
chant ty
on
encan
roy qui viennent nous voir parce que ils
essaient de retrouver les merveilleux
souvenirs qu'ils ont eue grâce à ses
mélodies
c'est un public qui a gardé sa mémoire
son coeur et sa mémoire je pense que les
gens écoutent ses chansons avec plaisir
des chansons qui étaient des chansons
commander des deux des mélodies faciles
des mélodies faciles à chanter en tous
les cas la chanson rock and roll avec
nancy holloway
oui
sans goût
ça n'aura pas de votre jeunesse et puis
ça sans même un petit peu déçue si con à
musique moderne jazz est là qu est ce
que vous appréciez les textes mais les
bana et d'amour
c'est très bien vraiment on se retrouve
40 ans projetée 40 ans en arrière c'est
vraiment bien
deux zéniths en palais des congrès ils
vont parcourir la france jusqu'en
décembre prochain
et même si de temps en temps les coins
ne sont plus aussi assuré qu autrefois
c'est tout une histoire de la chanson
populaire française qui défilent devant
un public comblé
merci à vous